à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
les gens pour les premiers quinze
minutes du film dense et j'ai de
l'argent sur l'écran et de des fleurs de
l'argent c'est comme d'aller au temple
ont fait la même chose d'autant que
souvent les gens ils jettent des fleurs
et de l'argent chez les dieux
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
non il ne s'agit pas d'une attaque
terroriste
c'est juste la sortie d'un film en inde
[Applaudissements]
c'est aujourd'hui la sortie du plus gros
films de l'histoire du cinéma indien
les salons ouverts dès 6h du matin et
déjà plus d'un million de billets sont
vendus
c'est simple les chiffres de
fréquentation ici faut pas lire dans vie
tous les gens de l'industrie du cinéma
en occident et vous allez voir que
l'amour des indiens pour leur cinéma
c'est vraiment à la folie à you happy to
aux baous validé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
baoum ben ali c'est une fresque
mythologique à la sauce indienne on
pourrait le comparer à gladiator ou game
of thrones mais avec beaucoup moins de
budget le film est projeté dans six
mille salles en inde et 3000 dans le
reste du monde il y a quelques semaines
le simple dévoilement de la bande
annonce avait provoqué des scènes
d'hystérie dans les cinéma indien
[Applaudissements]
la canadienne de vancouver paula mcglynn
travaille depuis quatre ans dans
l'industrie du cinéma indien à la
maladie
elle a même tenu le rôle principal dans
un petit film après avoir appris la
langue locale et s'est mis à dos les
steaks a calqué en inde du sud
l'acteur tamouls rajinikanth est
surnommée la superstar mais il est
encore plus que ça les gens édifier des
temples en son honneur et pour lui
souhaiter bonne chance à la sortie de
ses films il jette du lait et d'autres
offrande sur une gigantesque
représentation en carton la délit par
exemple
obsédé avec les stars là bas c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour moi de
sortir et tout d'un coup on crown
énorme qui vient de nulle part et on est
coincé
[Musique]
kalki cochelin est une actrice à part
parmi les vedettes de bollywood
né en inde il ya 33 ans de parents
français hippie elle a grandi dans ce
pays et se sent complètement indienne
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas du tout l'air
indien et geslin très française mais je
dis toujours ma peau est blanche mon
corps est marron
cette comédienne que vous ne connaissiez
sans doute pas est en fait l'actrice
francophones qui fait le plus d'entrées
en salles de toute la planète
c'est ce que marion cotillard c'est ce
qu'ils avaient dit non mais oui mais
c'est parce que
c'est un pays énorme à une population
énorme on aime et même la diaspora
indienne dans le monde entier non
et avec lui
m
tous les dimanches dans l'ordre de
mumbai un véritable pèlerinage se
produit nous sommes devant la maison
d'habitat bachchan un acteur de 74 ans
ultra populaire qui apparaît sur un
nombre incalculable de publicité en inde
des centaines de personnes attendent des
heures dans l'espoir de l'apercevoir
ce fan qui vient pour la quatrième fois
nous montre les photos de l'acteur qui
collectionne sur son téléphone
après une longue attente dans la chaleur
et l'oppression
l' apparition divine survient finalement
pour quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
en inde il ya des journaux consacrés
uniquement aux stars de bollywood et ce
qui est phénoménal c'est qu'en fait ils
sont assez épais l' envoi celui-là il a
environ une vingtaine de pages et il ya
différents quotidiens comme ça consacrer
uniquement aux stars de bollywood pour
saisir l'importance du cinéma en inde
on ne peut pas passer à côté du comédien
shah rukh khan c'est le deuxième acteur
le plus riche au monde
sa fortune est estimée à plus de 800
millions de dollars lui aussi apparaît
devant sa maison mais seulement deux
fois par année et sur une plateforme
spécialement construites
ok
dans ses mémoires
shah rukh kahn apparaît dans les films
grands publics et commerciaux de
bollywood
ceux qui ont fait le formidable succès
de ce cinéma en inde mais qui suscite
aussi moqueries et des intérêts en
occident sauf que les choses changent
depuis quelques années une génération
d'auteurs et cinéaste indien impose un
virage comme ça et ça commence à changer
petit à petit à bollywood
justement parce que l'internet et le
monde devient de plus en plus en plus
petits les indiens ont netflix et des et
des sources comme ça où il peut voir le
schéma mondiale et donc ils ont envie de
voir autre chose aussi des histoires
indienne mais qui sont pas
nécessairement bollywood c'est la main
les films maintien voyage de mieux en
mieux
ils sont très populaires en russie au
japon au moyen orient et en afrique era
sera ouvert et une fin si il ya bien sûr
toujours des cascades ridicule mais avec
un peu plus de budget on retrouve aussi
moins de copies des films d'hollywood
comme il ya quinze ans avec matrix
[Musique]
ce sont d'ailleurs ces plagiats qui ont
suscité le surnom bollywood dans les
années 70 à ce propos il faut faire une
mise au point importante appeler tout le
cinéma indien bollywood est une erreur
bollywood ce n'est que le cinéma en
langue hindi dont le centre de
production est à mumbai mais il ya aussi
qu hollywood en langue tamoule
pauli woods en pendjabi et bien d'autres
le film bat ou ben ali par exemple
dorénavant plus grands films indiens de
tous les temps n'est pas de bollywood
mais de tony wood en langue telugu
l'ensemble des cinémas indien produit
aujourd'hui deux fois plus de films que
les américains une véritable fierté
nationale qui fait que depuis quelques
mois
l'hymne national indien est obligatoire
au début des séances
[Musique]